welcome to Marwin is the most original
film of the year what happened to you I
got beaten within an inch of my life
because I was different some Nazi thugs
jumped him so I created a world where I
could be anyone I want these are the
women of Marwan the thousand people you
know
yeah there's bar Lala you can't keep on
running away Julie I got your pick
Roberta and Nicole I just moved any
Christmas gene this is hoagie kind of a
braver version of me we're one in the
same pal I thought I heard you yelling
for more gumbo not gumbo no gumbo this
Christmas the only way you're gonna get
better is if you face those jerks who
beat you up based on an inspirational
true story of a man who turned treasure
I got you what you gotta embrace the
Kmart into triumph I have my art and I
have my friends I have hope that's
something they can't take away from me
tail yeah
bottoms up girl
from the groundbreaking director of
force go don't just imagine yourself as
a hero be one in real life
welcome to home you are safe
welcome to healing to life to love to
Marwan
welcome to Marwan
[Music]